あのおゆまるってもう一度湯に入れるとまた柔らかくなるって聞いたんですけどなり
ませんでした
他の動画と廊下の動画鳥はを今ではまた今度することにします
なんでだろうね4背負いコイサー今回はこちらお買い物してきました久しぶりの
ショッピング動画ですえっと今回ですねあそこを買いました
パスゴンとか特にやりたくねーなーではさっそく開けていきましょう
待ってドーン釣ったよ
ろって言ったろ
あの子の開封の儀は僕の唯一の有酸素運動です
まったく意味のない行為で見えるんですけど運動不足の僕からすると
唯一の分銅なんですよ編集でカットしてさ
たなさそうに見えるけどさなんだよはい的だ
新しいパソコンですごいパソコンの名前は流
フォレスト pc くるスペックゲームデスクトップ office 搭載モデル
cpu コア愛せるメモリ16 gb ssd 120 gb へ一時1たらそういう
ものに行っておりますデスクトップ pc
なくてのパソコンだとできないこととかが結構あるんですゲームとかね色々こう
ウィングうれしかできないこととかもあるんで windows のパソコンを買わせ
ていただきました
昔はウィンドぞんですけど
持ってたんですけどちょっと調子が悪くて今のところ僕の持つ唯一の windows
のパソコンになります
うん
まってまっ
待てませんので全然ケーブル13プロセッサーうちて本題
待て集まってりゃー自作 pc かー待って待って待ってねこれさぁ自作 pc です
かね
自宅 pc マッターどうしようよこれ机のか自分で待ったちょっと居酒てみましょう
壊れ壊れじゃあなってるかと思ってたよっ子レジャーこれだけだろそれこういう感じの
顔になっております
町田中身にさあこれ中身ないよ中身がないまさかな山野内
中身が無いの神がだ言ってっ
線含みされちゃういやさーん
んだてがそうだ数回であっての中の飛んでこのパソコンは基本的には芸名をげーよと
windows でしかできないことよ3 bs とが ps vita とかでちゃ
ぷちゃ遊ぶウィンナーなっても行けるだけなんでマック用の世帯でパッション企業と
なるぞ動かないですけどウィンドズームが多分確実にできると思います今後ね
windows パソコンが必要になるかなと思いまして購入いたしまし
マイクラとかもこれでいけるかと思います
一応ここがゲームスレ部屋なんですけどもねぇもうそれ変異あそこセッティング初代
すればもう遊戯王する場所がなく夏ならここにこうねパソコンしたい気分となくさっき
のパソコンも9分
思ってるで腕置き場に困るなむしろこっち名物のかちょっと作戦併合でここにパソコン
をおきたいです
ってかも作りもさ面白か机を講師を前で普通にをフェアそうじゃんも公平感でパス防止
帯で机もちょっとピックと海底たショッパーせっかくの土日ながら2今日はお掃除10
日です今日はお掃除するよ
ハハッ発揮し
サッサッじゃあつで床を全部ポチっとウォッチピースやつっきゃぴゆああっっ
あとこのパソコンなんですけどスペック良くて安い前半の理由としてはモニター
トランスとキーボードは全部付いてません
リーダーミスでない偽書だーっ
何すとキーボード2学校の時結構パソコンが好きでパソコン兄弟見て寝ると思ってるん
ですけど迫のことは全くよくわかりません
ちょっと最近ちょっと待ってのパソコンを使ってたんですけどもやっぱりね
window 者
mac は使いやすくて簡単なんですけども windows の方ができることが
多いんだよ
ちょっと色々試してみます病気で肇社長の休日わたしっぱ
祖母のこのシステムが完成したという感じでしたぜひ皆さんジョイ休日を
じゃん
voodoo